you had this mainstream success that is
very glitzy and glammy and it's like a
lot of us chose podcasting because there
wasn't that opportunity there right so
this alternative Universe kind of was
created
um what is what has one been like in the
other been like well I mean I had first
so many years of just struggling you
know like uh I started when I was a just
18. I think the first time I ever did it
I was 17 but I started really trying at
18 in 1985. it's a long [__] time ago
it's 38 years now wow but from nine from
1985 and when I was 18 Till I was you
know it was a Boston comedian for years
just trying and failing and and uh and
then I moved to New York and I started
to get some sense of power but but and I
tried writing for TV as a way to make a
living because I just wasn't making it
as a comic but as a stand-up I worked
until it wasn't really until I was like
40 that I started to really like hit so
I had all those years so that's like
like a whole other you know right right
people kind of forget about that yeah I
wasn't trying to discredit you no no I
hadn't put your time feel that at all no
but after that then I had yeah I had
this big and the biggest part of it was
the stand-up I mean that's what fueled
it all was that I was selling out
theaters all of a sudden and they
couldn't get be big enough like I would
double the size and sell it out I would
put a show on sale and it would sell out
in a minute
and um
and there wasn't a room in the world
like there wasn't an indoor space in the
world I couldn't book
like we would me and my agent would talk
about where you want to play like let's
go to London Royal Albert Hall if you
feel like at Wembley Arena yeah just any
place Stonehenge yeah [__] Madison
Square Garden weird amphitheaters in the
ass Mr McGregor's Garden anywhere
anywhere it was crazy like I remember I
was talking about one point about
playing Central Park you know like Simon
Garfunkel did like it was crazy
and then the TV thing you know I mean I
had that show and it hit
but it wasn't like friends or something
it wasn't like you know what I mean it
wasn't a network show with a huge reach
there's still a [__] a ton of people
that never saw it it had pretty low
ratings in my show it got a lot of press
and rewards and stuff and not even as
many awards as other shows it wasn't
like the office or something right but I
loved the work I loved I was getting to
do the show exactly the way I wanted so
I had a huge fulfillment that way and
yeah it was weird I was getting Awards
and I was at awards shows and stuff like
that and I would meet somebody like Brad
Pitt and he'd be like oh dude and that
kind of strange feelings and
um I'm sure and your ego has to build
even if you don't know it the ego's so
that's right that's the thing that's you
that you got to be careful of you don't
know what your ego is doing you're just
success is very dangerous because
there's no warning signs on it there's
nothing cautionary about it in the
experience you just believe in it you're
just like this is all happening because
I'm good at this and because it's my
time and and here we go and anything
good that happens you go sure I'll do
that too yeah and you just keep letting
it load on and you don't think about
like you're seeing the uh American
Gangster it's Denzel Washington yes
there is the that you're watching him
quietly build this huge Empire and then
it's when he goes out in the white uh uh
fur coat to the fight he goes to a box
you mentioned white for coat and then
the head cop the Russell Crow goes who's
that guy and he's not aware that
somebody has just gone wait a minute
who's the guy in the white fur so when
you're like big getting bigger and
bigger somebody out there is going like
what's going on with that guy that guy's
flying awfully high and you you just
don't you're not aware of that you just
go this just keeps being good I'll do
next year I'll do 10 shows of the garden
I mean where does that go where do you
think that's going like now I look at it
like where do you thinking that's headed
like it just can't things that expand
explode right yeah it's unsustainable
for most artists in the world I mean
every comedian has that's even gotten
that big there's been some comeback to
Earth moment everybody every buddy who
gets that big right has whatever their
vulnerability is whatever their thing is
they're Achilles heel it's going to get
hit yeah because the world tests you and
it's also just more interesting to watch
somebody go down it's just part of life
life is a zero-sum game you know oh yeah
so but so yeah but having done stuff
like hosting Saturday Night Live Like a
bunch of times like that was never that
wasn't in my
in my sights like I didn't think these
things would happen to me I had
completely you're really not I
completely had given up on those things
happening to me I just admitted to being
a writer you think yeah I thought I'd
I'll never stop doing stand-up I thought
because I love it it's it's the thing I
love
but I can write I'm a good writer I
tried making films early and they
crashed and burned so I'm like I'm not
going to be a film director either those
are the Big Dreams like direct movies be
a comedian
I'm gonna do comedy but no one's ever
gonna love it and I'll go down for
whatever I was maybe pulling in a you
know a few hundred people a night down
it'll just diminish and someday I'll
have to give it up and I'll write and
that'll be okay I'll make other people
famous make Chris Rock famous make Conan
you know help other guys get there and
there's joy in that I Chris I I love
Chris this is my favorite growing up
yeah he he astonished me when he came
back to stand up after SNL and get
inspired me a lot he was he's one of the
best friends I've ever had and uh he was
a great bot when he was just my boss I
just loved him he was the greatest
greatest guy he used to say like you
know I'm not it's not about me world
because he he hired writers that were
all really good and he said we're all
the Yankees I'm I'm in the I'm in the
cleanup spot but I'm just the guy who
has this one role but you're all you
know you've made us feel like we're all
part of it right so I liked that work
but I had no I had really decided and I
started I had a kid and I was like this
is not
it's not gonna never gonna happen for me
and then if something changed because
when I went on stage I just didn't I
didn't care anymore about my a career so
and I was really cranky and I was
starting to really I went through a new
cranky phase and I was a tired father
and and I started talking about that and
then things then things changed you know
did it surprise you yeah really it
really did talk to me and then when I
got the this show on FX the the the they
paid me the minimum I got paid like you
know scale yeah and the show had the
smallest budget of any show on
television but the point was and it was
on FX which was nowhere at the time I
mean they had a few cool shows yeah but
people didn't know about it no so I
thought I'm gonna do a show and I'm
gonna love it
and it's never going to take off it's
just going to be a little show my friend
Laura kitlinger had done this show
called The Adventures of Jackie
something and Laura's one of the
funniest people I knew and she did a
nice season on like AMC and I thought
that's what I'm gonna do one season of
this weird little show and then I'll go
back to them I'll get another writing
job that's what I figured I had no
[__] and then we're like you know
then we're getting on the big lists and
then we got Emmy I was totally shocked
that that happened
um but then after a few years I'm like
yeah this is you know it's like if you
play Blackjack you start winning you get
stupid right away you're like I'm good
it's because I'm good at Blackjack yeah
yeah because I know what I'm doing
and then they just then you're busting
every hand you're like no I'm a [__]
[__] so yeah I was in a place where I
thought like I this is happening because
I know what I'm doing now because I'm
earning it but a lot of it is just so
weird you caught a wave you caught a
wave it was good timing yeah it's
interesting how some comedians don't
even get the time it's like they're
where they're what their funny is in
their lifespan it just doesn't match
with the wave of like where Society is
sometimes that's right there's some
people that are incredible but they
weren't that at the right time that's
one of the biggest challenges in comedy
is just staying good when nobody's
paying attention and continuing to
progress because it's like this search
light that maybe finds you sometimes and
if every time it finds you you're you're
getting better and better then the then
someone in the somebody in the world
will start to go this guy is a good bet
they'll start putting money on you yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one